is always a rise and a fall in NFL right
at one point you're always going to be
on top of the mountain football has a
funny way of keeping people humble right
and I'm not saying this is example for
San Francisco everyone has to deal with
these things in NFL versus his injuries
versus his adversity I mean I don't even
think the Dallas Cowboys could survive
three straight losses it's not so much
as it's pry cuz a lot of people are
saying it's pry and it's always easy to
blend a quarterback because when they
were winning it was always P's the
greatest I just think San Francisco has
to turn it around they're battling
adversity I definitely think the 49ers
will bounce back they're a great team I
don't think we should bury them for
their three straight losses I think the
49ers humbled us and I just think life
humbled them and it goes like that
sometimes